What up, guys?
Jason Silva here.
And welcome to Shots of Awe
on the TestTube Network.
Shots of Awe is a series
of interviews building
on my recent work, "My Shots
of Philosophical Espresso."
Shots of Awe offers a
series of reflections
on my current thinking
on the human condition,
the ways in which
we use technology
to transcend all previous
limits, the nature
of creativity, the nature of
what it means to be alive,
the role of philosophy
in everyday life.
Think of them as inspired
nuggets of techno rapture.
And we're going to have
new episodes every week.
So make sure you subscribe as
well as follow the social links
below.
And stay tuned and
check out testtube.com.
Thanks, guys.
Don't miss Shots of Awe.